much odd is because normally it would
something so kind of computer animation
and all that to herself yeah there's a
lot of green screens up but you actually
went to locations yeah I do think I
choose the great adjourn Bert Roberts
who directed it really was insistent
that we go to places on earth which are
both beautiful and dangerous so that it
didn't feel like a digital environment
it felt like a real place so we went to
a Wahoo in Hawaii dangerous yes very
windy every week we went the umbrella
blew out of my cocktail
we went to Queensland in Australia
that's scarier I'll get out there rain
forests there and they have the most all
the most dangerous animals in the world
are in the state of Queensland in
Australia yeah amazing yeah snakes
spiders some of Queens I got yeah I
escaped you know need to see the funnel
web spiders starting to Jesus they the
people to come to Australia they've got
the skill right they've got the most
poisonous spiders snakes jellyfish
sharks crocodiles and they walk around
in flip-flops yeah I think no that's why
that's why all the Menace recently yeah
they have to they have to be the [__]
bill alive
yeah yeah just out what could where
isn't where is your you adopted an
animal oh yeah oh yeah that yeah no I
adopted a cheetah actually I was in
Kenya okay yeah a little baby cheetah
pretty cute there we go actually in
fairness that is very tried to bring him
to London said it was impossible
correct yeah I could him tiny as well
with things like that would be so
gangster fabulous walking down Hanson
with the Taser
who's that I believe it's Tinie Tempah
well you know I was really happy to do
that we went to a night and I Robi
reserve Park okay and yeah it was a
pretty great experience and then also on
the flip side I'm kind of into taxidermy
I don't know if this is gonna
when you say the flipside yeah try
explaining that to tiny but only small
right now only if they only if they say
that they've like ever died of natural
causes but to be honest I don't know
what it is I think it's just maybe
African roots or whatever but I really
love that idea of being surrounded by
exotic animals in my house I have like a
zebra and I have a giraffe as well Wow
but not like a real one but like a it
was real before yeah yeah yeah yeah that
died of like natural like the flu and
stuff yeah that's right with a giraffe
it's the airway later is really bad you
got high ceilings and in your house
always drinking
died drinking hard to art that was
divers sleep of taxidermy animals
they're just laughs it would be it would
attack today
you can have me yeah it's just me I'm
threatened just so get my dog stuffed
when he died she wanted him stuffed and
put on the wall of our lovely dogs head
hot dog was called said Oh lovely lovely
black cloud on a black stuff his head oh
did she do it no okay oh it would have
been quite funny but she did she liked
the idea of it yeah it's not that wasn't
about breaking yeah quite nice yeah what
are you giving out this stuff to sleep
by the fire so it's nice yeah that would
make me on it whoa yeah hard to explain
to the new dog
beginning 15 I keep my pajamas but
you're afraid
oh well what are you afraid of well
anything in Australia basically yeah um
sharks very rational hey I'm this yeah I
mean I mean you should be you you get
scared of sharks and basis whether
cannot be shot internet cafes cause I
had a fit always they come through the
flap I still do if I'm honor in a
swimming pool my own I just get
something like I am with myself I think
those flowers from what if it comes
through that flat what if I don't know
how a shot would obviously get through
there but I have the same player and
it's from I I think it's from your
Thunder ball Thunder ball you know in
fundable the Bond film yes and the
villain Largo has two two swimming pools
he does and people get chucked into the
swimming pool
and if you've behaved badly they
released the grill and the Sharks come
into that's what it this might be a bit
weird guys would you ever get a similar
thing but on the toilet
there's anything imagine of something
just spiders phobia or the poster of
Joel's aloud I worry more about things
that come out
[Applause]
[Music]